- Today we're gonna do something
very special and very serious.
We're gonna play a little
game I like to call,
is this this a real place in Pennsylvania
or just some sex words?
- Didn't know it was gonna be a sexy quiz.
- A real place in Pennsylvania
or just some sex words?
- That's pretty specific.
- [Boy In Plaid] Intercourse
(chuckling)
- Intercourse really cuts through all
the b.s. and it just, yeah, our town's
named after people having sex.
- Okay, well I know this is a sex word.
- That's not a real place.
- That's probably not
a town in Pennsylvania.
- Just a sex word.
Oh, it's actually a town.
- I don't know if I got
that right or wrong.
- What do they do in intercourse?
Probably a lot of holding
hands I would imagine.
- [Girl In Red] Deep hole.
- What I wouldn't give is to be
from a town named deep hole.
- Deep hole.
(laughing)
- Deep hole, deep hole, deep hole.
- Deep hole can refer to your ear.
- I'm gonna say deep hole is a place
in Pennsylvania.
(laughing)
- Your belly button.
- That's probably not
a city in Pennsylvania?
- Or your anus.
- That was just a sex word
(laughing)
Is that even a sex word?
Who say that? Deep hole?
- How deep is the hole?
Is it like a tourist attraction?
There something fun going on there?
Crotch.
(laughing)
- Great name for a place, very powerful.
Aren't we all from crotch?
- Sex word.
- Sex word?
- Everybody's got one.
- Who is gonna name a place crotch?
(laughing)
I knew it.
Okay, nobody's that stupid.
- If Pennsylvania had a crotch
it would be right around here.
- It would be the closest
place to New Jersey.
- [Boy In Plaid] Oh, climax Pennsylvania.
- Climax should be the
capital of Pennsylvania.
If you want tourist to come,
then you gotta have
climax as your capital.
- I feel like it could be a town name.
- Okay, I'm just gonna
say this is a sex word.
It is a
(beep)
place in Pennsylvania.
Why is everyone in Pennsylvania so horny?
- Everybody wants to come there, boom.
Bald Knob.
- Literally, they named
their town shaved penis.
Imagine being from a
place named shaved penis.
That would be pretty cool.
- Bald knob
(chuckling)
- Kind of wanna throw up
just looking at the word.
I'm gonna like hope that
it's just a sex word,
because I never ever, ever want
to go to bald knob
Pennsylvania if it exists.
Oh.
- Arkansas?
- Aren't we talking about Pennsylvania?
Where did Arkansas come from?
- I just don't want
anything to do with this.
I don't want anything
to do with this anymore.
- [Boy In Plaid] Big beaver.
- Like they saw one big beaver
and they were like,
(beep)
that's it.
That's the name of our town.
- It's gotta be a town.
There's plenty of towns named after,
like, animals and things.
- What does big beaver mean?
(chuckling)
(inaudible whispering)
Ohhh.
(laughing)
It makes sense now.
- Big beaver is definitely a place.
- Yeah, I'm gonna go
with Pennsylvania town.
Yes, nice.
I would have a little
bit of fun in that town,
not gonna lie.
- Well today I learned that there's a lot
of weird towns in Pennsylvania.
- I learned that people have dirty minds.
- I learned what a big beaver is.
- People from Pennsylvania,
damn, you guys are some kinky mofos.
(light jazz music)